hello readers
i would like to show you one of my
favorite things i ever wrote
it's this splash page from a comic i
wrote some years ago illustrated by my
friend core biladu you'll notice it has
almost no words in it at least in this
form
now let me show you the script
pages three and four panel one
a double page spread the whole
greenhouse revealed in widescreen it's
glorious wisps of steam curl up from
bubbling patches of pool
green kelpy tendrils twine up the sides
of the building
everything is diffused with a delicate
green glow absent the grow lights some
of the algae fluoresce in a range of
cool spectrum colors but primarily
greens
eugene is dwarfed by its almost cosmic
magnificence
caption
i can't describe it
none of that language except for the
caption shows up in the final layout all
of that was me the writer giving art
direction to core the illustrator then
they translated that language into their
own version
i think it's a pretty faithful
translation
my words are translated through core's
design sensibilities and turned into
artwork
when you translate a written work into a
different medium whether it's
illustrated animated recorded or
performed live it changes
it becomes a fundamentally different
object
as readers it's a valuable skill to
explore how a text changes as it shifts
from one medium to another and when i
say medium i mean a style of work like a
stage play a film a graphic novel an
audio drama any of that
good readers analyze those changes and
use them to understand decisions that
creators make
if you're watching romeo and juliet and
the director has made the decision to
dress everyone in towering robot suits a
detail that is definitely not in the
play as written what does that decision
tell you
what does it mean to you maybe you have
had the experience of reading a book
series that was important to you and
then they made it into a movie and you
were so excited to see the movie and you
sat down to see it and it was awful like
they cast the wrong actors and they
simplified the plot until it made no
sense and it just didn't
feel
right
that feeling is an example of this
tension this change between a written
material and its visual adaptation
sometimes it can be bad sometimes it can
be good
some readers can imagine what characters
in books look or sound like hearing them
in their mind's ear seeing them in their
mind's eye
the way your imagination renders a
character is going to be different from
how someone else's imagination does it
so let's compare the script for this
audio drama we've got on khan academy
hands off my phone and let's compare
that against the recorded version so
first i'm going to put up the script and
i'd like you to pause the video and just
read it to yourself very quickly
and now let's take a listen to the
recorded version
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no he didn't that is so harsh right
your dad took your phone away just for
getting a d on the history test yep my
mind is blown mine too i mean that was
an easy test what i can't believe you
got a d hey that's not really and your
dad is the school principal and he took
your phone away whoa you know
this isn't really helping your life is
so bleak right now
so you can read that script and think oh
hey sebastian is being earnestly
sympathetic like he really recognizes
that his friend is hurting but when you
hear that performance the way i
interpreted this line
is that sebastian is low-key roasting
valentina he's not saying your life is
so bleak in a kind way he's rubbing salt
into the wounds and being a dingus about
it
there's also other stuff that's not
explicitly in the script like that
opening musical sting
and the ringing of the bell
or those background school noises all of
that is meant to represent the fact that
you're listening to a fictional show
that takes place in a school setting
does it work
that's for you to decide
when you watch or listen to a
performance or recording or when you
look at illustrations ask yourself some
questions
for an audio piece how do the sound
effects the acting decisions and the
music impact the story or affect the
meaning of the words the characters say
how does the way that an actor delivers
a line change its emphasis was someone
being sarcastic or sincere in a way you
didn't expect for example
for an illustrated story how do those
illustrations help you understand the
author's tone
and do you agree with those choices is
the author's interpretation of the story
the same as yours
for a tv show or a movie or a play in
addition to all the decisions made by
actors about how to use their voices
shape their faces or hold their bodies
how does the set tell the story how do
costumes tell the story how does
lighting or special effects impact the
tone
for tv and film how does the camera
impact the way the story is told
the way a piece of film text is edited
its cuts its angles its rhythms can help
shape the way you as a viewer as a
reader of visual text
understand it
and if you can learn that
then you can learn anything
dave it out